SIERRA: Okay, so the funny thing about recording
a podcast from your home during a quarantine,
is that you might end up spending a lot of
time in your closet. It may seem strange,
but you get the best sound in a
small room with lots of padding.
So, the reason I’m telling you this, is because
today’s episode is about clothes. And there’s no
better place to talk about them than here,
in my very full, very disorganized closet.
The thing is, I love shopping. Shopping
makes me feel good. It’s exciting.
And the decision about whether or not
to buy something has always boiled down
to two things. One, how badly I wanted it,
and two, whether or not I could afford it.
But what if the real cost of my clothes
has nothing to do with the price tag?
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters,
today what is Fast Fashion? And
what is it doing to our world?
Mean Girls:
Get in loser we’re going shopping.
Sex and the City: I spent 40,000
on shoes and have nowhere to live?
Queer Eye: Yas! Yas!
Emily Mariko:
There are a ton of matching separates out
there in stores right now and it's really fun.
Shea Whitney: Their trends
are just always on point.
INMYSEAMS: I grabbed I think 17 items
...the top was $14.99, the skirt was $34.99.
Teen Vogue: We all love to shop and these days the
newest styles and clothes are cheaper than ever.
John Oliver: We buy a lot
of clothes in this country.
SIERRA: So what is fast fashion?
GREER: So what fast fashion means is,
just the rate of turnover of clothing
in stores every several weeks.
I'm Linda Greer and I'm an environmental
toxicologist. I study and advocate on
industrial toxic chemical pollution.
So, back in the day, stores basically had
four seasons and you went in seasonally
to buy whatever clothing that you
wanted. And your expectations were
not such that if you went back in two
weeks, you would buy it all over again.
SIERRA: Sure.
GREER: But then, with fast fashion, basically,
this dramatic lowering of prices and a new sort
of marketing model that draws consumers
in, at any time to see what's new,
what we found was this immense acceleration of
people buying clothing and people buying things
that they might even never wear. Or only wear
a few times, and it's sort of a whole mindset
shift from buying things we really love and
buying things you think will last, sort of a
timeless fashion, to use a really dated term.
Which would probably be my parents' generation.
SIERRA: Right. As opposed to me when I'm like,
"I'm going out tonight. I should get a shirt."
GREER: I need something new.
SIERRA: Yeah.
GREER: Right. Not to mention,
you know, I think the impact of
Instagram where people feel like they
need to look different on every shot.
SIERRA: Sure.
GREER: All of these things have had
a very corrosive effect because, from
an environmental standpoint, that's just massive
throughput. That's just massive amounts of fabric,
massive amounts of apparel, you know, coming
into these stores and it's fair to say that
almost no matter what these factories
do if they're making that much stuff,
their carbon footprint, water use, and chemical
use, and pollution is just very hard to curtail.
SEGRAN: When we think about how
enormous the fashion industry is,
it starts to become clear what kind
of impact it has. Hi. I'm Liz Segran.
I'm the senior staff writer at Fast Company
magazine and I focus on the fashion industry.
So for instance, in 2015, a hundred
billion articles of clothing were
manufactured. And if you think about
how there's just over seven billion
people on the planet that is
a lot of clothing per person.
SIERRA: A hundred billion
pieces of clothing a year,
and I’m probably buying more than my fair share.
And what have I gotten out of them? Looking
around my closet there’s a lot of things I love,
and still wear. But there are also some
I’ve never worn, and quite a few I’ve
only worn once or twice. They served their brief
purpose, and are now just kinda taking up space.
SEGRAN: Given how the fast fashion industry
works, the clothes that are on the shelves
are really sort of designed to be on trend for the
season. So that article of clothing that you buy,
you know, you're probably going to
wear that for a season, two seasons,
at most a couple of years and then you're going
to chuck that away. And so basically all of the
carbon that was involved in shipping
all of those items across the world,
all of the labor that went into that,
all of the chemicals that went into that,
it basically goes into a very short-term purchase
ultimately, and if you just think about that
magnified by every human on the planet, you begin
to get a sense of how enormous this industry is.
SIERRA: According to the United Nations
Alliance for Sustainable Fashion,
the $2.4 trillion apparel industry accounts
for 8 to 10% of the world’s greenhouse gas
emissions. That’s more than all international
flights and maritime shipping combined. These
are staggering numbers. But it’s important
to take them with a grain of salt.
SIERRA: So this obviously sounds like a huge
issue. How reliable are the statistics in this?
GREER: Ah. So this is the point
in which the podcast needs to
be a video so I can be wringing my
hands so that people could see. The
numbers that are associated with this
industry are extremely poor quality.
This has made me crazy because they've
been poor quality for almost a decade.
SEGRAN: I think that the fashion industry is
a very complex global industry, but there are
other highly complex global industries out there
like the transportation industry, like the oil
industry, and yet we have relatively good figures
about the impact that they have. And I think that
that's because these industries have been under
scrutiny for longer and there are government
imposed consequences on them. So as a result,
there's been more academic research, government
research done to assess these industries, and
this has not happened in the fashion industry.
SIERRA: Part of the problem is that production
in the fashion industry is piecemeal. So,
it’s likely that the materials in the
shirt you’re wearing passed through
middleman after middleman, across
many countries, before you bought it.
The path varies, but let’s take a hypothetical
cotton shirt. So, the cotton might be grown
in Brazil, the U.S., or maybe even Uzbekistan.
Once harvested it’s off to, say, China or India,
to be twisted into yarn, or woven into fabric.
Then it gets dyed. But it’s not over yet,
the fabric is off to another location, maybe
Bangladesh, Vietnam, or Honduras to be cut,
trimmed, and assembled — this is all before
it can be shipped to a store or your doorstep
as a finished product.
All along the way,
those materials are leaving a trail of wastewater,
industrial chemicals, air pollution, and carbon.
SEGRAN: There are so many people involved
with the fashion industry. And so basically
companies are only working with a couple of
players in their supply chain at any one time.
And so if you ask a company to survey itself and
provide data about the impact that it's having,
it's only going to actually know a couple
of the most recent steps in the process,
right. And so I think it's just a very, very
difficult thing to do to sort of trace a garment
all the way back to the raw materials that
it was made of. I previously mentioned that
a hundred billion articles of clothing
were made in 2015. 15 years before that,
in 2000 only 50 billion articles of clothing
were manufactured. So in that 15 year period, the
number of clothes manufactured globally doubled.
And actually according to surveys, there are some
garments that some of us buy that are only worn
eight to ten times before we throw them away.
SIERRA: I mean, what's wild about this
is that this seems to have gotten worse
since the world has sort of
woken up to climate change.
SEGRAN: We're seeing all of these horrible things
happening and we're seeing exactly how
bad the climate crisis is going to be,
and yet this is still the infrastructure
through which we buy our clothes.
SIERRA: It’s hard to learn that something
you love is harming the world around you.
And that made me want to talk to someone
who loves fashion as much as I do,
someone in the industry. So I did what anyone
in my situation would do, I called a supermodel.
VALLETTA: My name is Amber Valletta and I'm
a model, an activist, and an entrepreneur.
SIERRA: Aside from being seen on the
runway and on the cover of Vogue,
Amber formed her own company called Master and
Muse. And she had some really great advice.
VALLETTA: I started thinking about what I wanted
to do with my, my life, my career. And sort of,
you know, what kind of legacy did I wanna leave
behind for my son. So that was the impetus
for me to start Master and Muse, which was an
online store for responsibly made fashion and
accessories, and sort of the thought leadership
and work that I've been doing in fashion to
get the fashion industry to become aware of
sustainability, but also consumers and how
we can think differently about our clothes. So I
suggest, you know, in the next few days, you go
into your closet and your dresser drawers and you
look at what you have and you really take stock.
SIERRA: Ok so Amber told me to take
stock, so let’s take stock. Okay,
so there's a lot of stuff in here. There is a
little bit of a method to this madness. There's
shoes down there and there's long sleeve shirts
up here. And then to the right we have pants. This
shirt I have in three versions. Jump cut to, I’ve
worn the white one and not the other two at all.
So looking around at all this stuff I am
realizing that a lot of it is, in fact,
fast fashion, and a lot of it doesn’t get
used, and that never bothered me before
because it was cheap, or at least affordable,
and yeah it’s starting to bother me now.
SIERRA: So, okay, I know the clothes we
wear travel all across the world while
they’re being made, but could
you walk me through, sort of,
the environmental impact at each of those
stages? How is my shirt polluting the world?
GREER: Yeah. So would you like
to talk about a cotton shirt?
So, first of all, cotton is a very difficult
crop to grow. It is a very thirsty crop. That
means it needs a lot of water. It is hammered
by insects, so it requires a lot of pesticides.
And in order to get a good yield, it really
likes to have fertilizer. And so when you
look at the cultivation of cotton, it is not
a walk in the park. In fact, that crop alone
uses more than 15% of all the insecticides
we use for any crop anywhere in the world.
SIERRA: Wow.
GREER: It then needs to be, sort of processed
into fibers, and prior to doing the spinning,
it needs to be scoured and sort of hammered away
with a lot of detergent and scouring agents to
take off the natural waxes that come along with
the cotton ball. So, you know, it goes through a
ginner and then it gets really hammered away and
then it finally gets spun. In order to get woven,
it needs to be coated with a chemical because the
fibers themselves are not very strong. They're not
strong enough to be woven without sizing on them.
Sizing is sort of like a starch that gets put on,
that later when it gets washed off, is very bad
for the rivers that receive it. And then when it's
finally woven that starch has to be taken off,
and we're finally ready to dye it and finish it.
SIERRA: Wow. That's already a lot
of chemicals you just mentioned.
GREER: It's already a lot, and I gotta
tell ya, one more thing about cotton,
is that it doesn't like to accept dye. And
so they need to add more chemicals to allow
those things to come together, including
salt. So, overall for a fiber that gets,
I think for many people, sort of a
free ride, it is a problematic fiber.
SIERRA: The UN estimates that a
single pair of jeans requires a
kilogram of cotton. And because cotton
tends to be grown in dry environments,
producing enough for that pair of jeans consumes
about 10 years of drinking water for one person.
When scaled up, this can be devastating. In
2014, NASA revealed images showing that the
Aral Sea had effectively disappeared after rivers
were diverted for cotton farms in Uzbekistan.
And fabric production doesn’t just consume water,
it pollutes it too. Roughly 8,000
synthetic chemicals are used across
the world to produce textiles. Accounting
for 17 - 20% of industrial water pollution.
SIERRA: So, it really seems like, you know,
this shirt leaves a chemical and carbon
trail all the way across the world.
GREER: Yes. So I would like you to think about
your clothing as having embedded carbon in them.
Think about, it looks just like a shirt, but
how much energy went into that shirt that you're
complicit with that carbon emission even if it
didn't happen in your country. And then similarly,
it has embedded water use and it has embedded
chemical use and we don't see those embedded, sort
of footprints, in any of the things that we buy.
And, by the way, it's very difficult to get that
information. So I certainly don't blame consumers
for not having a little quantitative calculator
in their head of where their biggest embedded
carbon lies. But when they buy clothing, there's
a lot of environmental impact that was left in
the wake of the manufacturing of that stuff.
SEGRAN: I actually think that it's the
accumulation of all of those steps that is
the problem, and I think that that's partly why
it's hard for the average person to get a sense
of how enormous the problem is and sometimes
we see news stories about things like, "oh,
you know, what is the impact of e-commerce?”
Right, like “how much energy is used to ship
those products to us?” That is one tiny part
of this whole process, the only part that we
are able to visualize or make sense of. And I
actually think that part of the reason that the
fashion industry has gotten away with so much
environmental destruction is because the entire
supply chain is so broken up and there's so many
middlemen along the way that it's really hard
to point a finger at any one part of this chain
and make somebody take responsibility for that.
SIERRA: What sort of regulation
is happening currently?
SEGRAN: There's hardly any at all.
GREER: This is a really low-tech industry, it
is operating much the way it operated, you know,
decades ago. I think that the difference is
that it's operating in the developing world,
in economies like China, in transition.
So, when it was operating here in the
United States and Europe, which was really only
about 15 or even 20 years ago it was operating
under a very mature environmental regulatory
system that was in place by our government,
the Environmental Protection Agency, that
had rules, regulations, it had inspections
and enforcement and the industry was very
well controlled. What happened then was,
you know, the big wave of globalization
where our manufacturing left our shores,
sort of in search for cheaper, cheaper,
goods, which now we all enjoy purchasing.
SIERRA: That's so interesting. You don't
think about it moving backwards that way.
GREER: No. And I have to say, you know,
I worked for the Natural Resources
Defense Council for almost 30 years. We
observed the pattern of globalization,
of course. We watched the trade agreements, et
cetera, get negotiated and we did push back on
some of the weaknesses in terms of environmental
matters in those agreements. But I have to say,
we did underestimate the environmental impact
of globalization. We really didn't think that,
you know, more than 80% of our, let's say,
textile factories would leave this country.
SEGRAN: I think a lot of brands are at this point
trying to self-regulate. You see lots of brands
making promises about how they're, you know,
trying to be carbon neutral or carbon positive,
and there are other brands that are saying,
"Oh, we're not going to use anymore virgin or
new plastic in our clothing, we're
going to use recycled plastic.”
GREER: A lot of these companies have
a small effort underway. Some
of them are just greenwashing.
SIERRA: And what's greenwashing?
GREER: Greenwashing is when they pretend
that they care, but they don't care.
VALLETTA: You know, these companies that get on
the bandwagon about, you know, a new packaging
that might be eco-friendly, or maybe they claim to
be organic but they're only partially organic, or
sometimes you find out that
they're not doing a whole lot.
SIERRA: Linda and Amber are right,
phony sustainability won’t actually
help the environment in the long
run. But some people think that
greenwashing might actually be
a good sign for the short term.
SEGRAN: My take on this is that I actually
think that it's really great that brands are
now feeling pressure to make these claims
about sustainability. I think that is an
important first step because for a long
time brands were manufacturing with highly
polluting practices with impunity. Now, I see
this as a sign that these brands are responding
to consumers’ desire for more eco-friendly
manufacturing and more eco-friendly clothing.
SIERRA: Right. I mean, the idea that it's a
marketing tool at all seems to be a good sign.
SEGRAN: I think so, yeah, and so now the next
step is just holding these brands into account
and kind of putting pressure on them to raise
the bar and raise their standards of what it
really means to be eco-friendly. What we need,
is we need governments to force companies to take
responsibility for the pollution that they're
producing and the impact that they're having
because right now, you know, it's citizens who
are paying the price for all of this destruction.
SIERRA: There is reason to
be hopeful. Some countries,
like France, have started making moves in the
right direction, and addressing the problem.
SEGRAN: So in France, there's a woman. She
is part of the Ministry of Ecological and
Inclusive Transition, which is basically France's
department in the government that's devoted to
sustainability, and her name is Brune Poirson.
And she has made the fashion industry kind of
her pet project. And so some of the things that
she's done for instance is she has banned fashion
companies from destroying their own merchandise.
Now, that should seem like an obvious thing for
a brand not to be doing, but it's actually pretty
common in the fashion industry particularly among
high fashion brands to basically destroy
their merchandise at the end of a season,
anything that's unsold because they
don't want those products to end up
on a second-hand market or to be discounted
because that will impact the brand equity.
SIERRA: Wow. That's awful by the way.
SEGRAN: It's so terrible. So these beautiful
luxury handbags have been essentially incinerated
and burnt for a long time. But actually this
is also happening in the fast fashion sector,
because in the fast fashion sector they
have a completely different problem which
is that they tend to produce so many clothes
every season that they just have this huge
stockpile of things that they just can't get
rid of. There's no way for them to sell it all
or donate it all. So they're also burning
it. And so if you think about all of the
steps that went into producing something
that will just ultimately get incinerated,
it's just horrible to think about. So in France,
they have banned this practice so companies cannot
do this anymore. And that actually has a
ripple effect, where these companies then
need to be a lot more responsible about how
much they're producing in the first place.
SIERRA: Right. Like you don't want it
to go out on the open market, you know,
for half price, fair enough,
then don't produce as much.
SEGRAN: Exactly. And so this is going to put the
onus on them to be much better
at tracking supply and demand.
SIERRA: Aside from a few ambitious policy makers,
there are also scientists and designers who are
trying to find creative solutions to the problem.
One of these solutions is algae. Marine microalgae
can be used to make clothes that are biodegradable
and far less energy and water intensive than other
fabrics. Or how about leather made from mushrooms?
No cows, no methane, no problem. And there’s
a lot more to come. But, for the time being,
it can feel like all the existing options are
harmful. So what can we do in the meantime?
GREER: So, you could ask your
favorite companies, rhetorically,
on Twitter or send them an e-mail,
how transparent is your supply chain?
Do you evaluate your suppliers for their
environmental performance before you
qualify them to make your stuff? What are
the consequences of egregious environmental
behavior? Have you benchmarked your suppliers
for who has the lowest carbon footprint? And
make some very tangible requests of them, to try
to pressure them to up their game and be real.
VALLETTA: Really take stock in the
things that could maybe be altered
and be made more modern for today. Simply
like changing a hem length. Guys, you can
cut off those pants and make them into shorts.
SIERRA: Don't encourage them
to make jean shorts. No.
VALLETTA: But simple things. Like if you have
a favorite pair of jeans, they might be kinda
cool with a patch. You know, dying a blouse,
with some natural dye. Just rethinking what
you have and making it last longer. You know,
play around with your wardrobe and you can make
subtle changes. Have swaps with your friends.
Also, if you're going to clean out your closet,
don't throw anything in the trash,
find a recycling bin for clothing.
SIERRA: So I’m still looking around my
closet, and I’m still seeing things I love.
But, you know, I’m having a hard time now
un-seeing the global cost of each piece,
the path each piece took to get to me. Whether
that's wastewater, whether that's carbon in the
air, whether that’s dried up rivers. It all is
here hanging in front of me too. And you know
Amber’s right, I can’t undo what I’ve already
bought, they’re now mine, they are part of my
footprint, as well as part of my closet.
But I guess the best possible thing I can do
is get the best use out of the things that I
have here, with me now. Ok so there's a bunch
of stuff in here that I guess I can update
a bit, but there's also a lot in here that
I can give to my friends. Which is the best
part, so let's start making some piles for
my friends. Ok well first of all obviously this
striped shirt would look really good on Frida...
SEGRAN: I think we're at the very beginning,
and this is what scares me because there's so
much that we know now about how quickly the Earth
is going to be impacted by climate change. And so
we really need to speed this whole process
up if we're really going to effect change.
SIERRA: Okay, so without a blockbuster statistic,
how do you convey the urgency of this problem?
GREER: So, people need to learn to live
without that blockbuster statistic,
but here's what for sure is true. The tremendous
amount of clothing that they buy is having a
tremendous impact. They can be assured that if
they buy less, they will have less impact and
if the clothes they buy come from companies
that are more responsible, it will be even
better. So they don't need specific numbers
to know that, basically, the magnitude of
this problem is very large, very significant
and there's something they can do about it.
SIERRA: Look, there’s no industry more sensitive
to consumer preferences than fashion. And if we
can truly make waste uncool, if we
can stigmatize needless production,
then the industry, and the regulators who
have the power to govern it, can change.
So… buy accordingly.
Want to learn more about fast fashion and
sustainability? Visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes for this
episode. We know there’s a lot going on out there,
and while this podcast is going to be focusing
on other topics, our sister podcasts The World
Next Week and The President’s Inbox
are providing in-depth coronavirus
coverage, and we encourage you to take a listen.
Interested in saying hi to the Why It Matters
team? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org. Be
sure to subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you like the show, leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created and
produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is Markus
Zakaria and our assistant producer is Rafaela
Siewert. Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri
Torjussen. Special thanks go to
Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you next time!